cain la parole est à monsieur laurent
wauquiez monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
appris ce matin que plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de nos compatriotes
subissent des retards importants dans le
versement de leur retraite
la conséquence est que certains assurés
se retrouvent sans ressource
durant des mois cette situation est non
seulement inadmissible mais elle est
surtout symbolique de la façon dont
votre gouvernement traite les retraités
les faits monsieur le premier ministre
ont la tête dure vous n'avez cessé de
pénaliser le pouvoir d'achat des
retraites avec des fonctions comme
jamais ponction avec la contribution de
solidarité pour l'autonomie ponction
avec la fiscalisation de la majoration
10 % des pensions des retraités ayant eu
au moins trois enfants ponction avec les
augmentation de la csg
sans même parler de la fiscalité des
ménages ou du prix de journée dans les
maisons de retraite et dans le même
temps monsieur le premier ministre vous
n'avez même pas fait l'effort minimal de
respect de solidarité qui aurait
consisté à revaloriser décemment le
minimum vieillesse à peine 1,7 pour cent
depuis avril 2010 est alors que pendant
le quinquennat précédent notre majorité
l'avaient revaloriser de 25%
nous avions fait le choix du respect des
retraités vous fait celui du mépris
aujourd'hui des français qui ont
pourtant travaillé pendant toute leur
vie peinent à joindre les deux bouts en
raison des augmentations d'impôts
successifs que vous leur avez imposé
quand allez vous enfin prendre en compte
la situation des retraités de france
comment espérer redonner espoir à la
france qui travaille quand les espoirs
de toute une vie ne suffisent plus à
garantir une retraite décente
nous vous accusons monsieur le premier
ministre d'avoir abandonné les retraités
vous sous-estimez leur colère les
retraités n'ont que faire de vos
soi-disant remords sur les impôts l'enea
culpa ne suffisent pas aujourd'hui ils
attendent de vraies geste les retraités
s'inscrivent dans la longue litanie des
promesses faites par le candidat
hollande et elles ne seront jamais
tenues
merci monsieur wauquiez la parole est à
madame la ministre des affaires sociales
de la santé et le rend les femmes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
wauquiez mais quelle outrance dans vos
propos
quelle manière de mettre à mal la
solidarité nationale est ce que
l'ensemble de la communauté nationale
qu'on sent comme efforts en direction
des retraités
monsieur le député la première chose que
nous avons faite en direction des
retraités c'est de rétablir l'équilibré
des comptes de nos caisses de retraite
qui garantisse à tous les retraités de
france comme vous dites à tous les
retraités que leur retraite seront
versés dans la durée nous nous sommes
préoccupés ce qui n'a pas l'air de vous
avoir touché est concerné monsieur le
député nous nous sommes préoccupés des
plus modestes des retraités en
revalorisant à 800 euros le minimum
vieillesse en permettant le cumul de
minimum vieillesse et d'un emploi en
permettant le versement d'une prime
spécifique de 40 euros pour tous les
retraités qui gagne qui ont une retraite
de moins de 1200 euros
et puis monsieur le député parce que les
retraités
ce sont des retraites versées mais c'est
aussi une attention aux conditions de
vie quotidienne à la prévention de la
dépendance et au soutien des personnes
âgées nous faisons voter avec laurence
rossignol une loi d'accompagnement de la
société au vieillissement qui va
permettre de mieux prendre en charge la
dépendance de mieux prendre en charge
les aides techniques dont nos
concitoyens les plus âgés ont besoin
plus d'heures dead d'appât pour moins
d'argent monsieur le député saad est pas
fou qui allait nous donner des leçons de
solidarité
ça n'est pas vous qui allez nous dire
comment nous devons mener
à bien la solidarité dont les retraités
de ce pays doivent légitimement à temps
parce que cette solidarité nous la
mettons en oeuvre au quotidien
merci madame la ministre pour le groupe
socialiste